North Korea's latest test like the one
seen here this time it appears to have
been a medium or intermediate-range
missile fired towards the Sea of Japan
but Japanese officials say the
projectile does not seem to have hit the
country's territorial waters the launch
came as Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo
Abe a was spending a weekend with Donald
Trump at the US presidents Florida State
the North Korean test is the first since
Trump took office both leaders condemned
the move
North Korea's most recent missile launch
is absolutely unacceptable
Yun Yin thank you Sam North Korea must
fully comply with the relevant UN
Security Council resolutions I just want
everybody to understand and fully know
that the United States of America stands
behind Japan it's great Ally 100% thank
you North Korea's repeated missile tests
and aggressive statements continue to
alarm the region and beyond Pyongyang
recently warned it was ready to test a
new intercontinental missile capable of
reaching the United States
[Music]
you